Такої "страшенної корупції", як тепер,
в Україні ще ніколи не було. Так стверджує
Олександр Вілкул - кандидат у президенти України
від партії "Опозиційний блок - партія миру і розвитку".
- Корупція в нашій державі страшенна. Завжди була
в країні корупція, але такої страшенної,
як зараз на всіх рівнях, не було ніколи.
Корупція - не таке вже й абстрактне явище.
Її можна виміряти і визначити в конкретних цифрах.
Щороку міжнародна організація Transparency International
оприлюднює Індекс сприйняття корупції.
В Україні цей показник розраховується
на основі майже десятка джерел. Це опитування
і дослідження авторитетних міжнародних організацій,
експертів та підприємців. Чим більше балів -
тим менше корупції в суспільстві, чим менше -
тим більше корупція пронизує усі рівні в державі.
Так от, за 2018 рік Україна отримала 32 бали і
посіла 120 місце зі 180 країн світу.
Це найгірше місце в Європі, але краще, ніж у Росії,
яка отримала 28 балів і посіла 138 місце.
Разом із тим у 2013 році, коли Олександр Вілкул,
власне, був віце-прем’єр-міністром в уряді Азарова
за президентства Януковича,
результат був відчутно гіршим: 25 балів і 144 місце.
Україна опинилася в компанії Папуа Нової Гвінеї та Нігерії.
Це найгірший результат із 2012 року, відколи
Transparency International Україна почала
застосовувати нову методологію обчислення корупції.
За висновками експертів цієї організації,
саме у 2013-му, коли Вілкул був при владі,
тиск на бізнес посилився, родина президента нищила конкуренцію,
чиновники ледь не за кожен дозвіл вимагали хабарі.
Після Революції гідності ситуація почала поліпшуватися,
але дуже повільно. У 2014-му
робота антикорупційних органів була лише в планах,
дані держреєстрів ще закриті, але бізнес
уже відзначав часткове зменшення хабарництва.
У 2015-му з’явилися численні журналістські розслідування,
але покарань топ-корупціонерів не було.
У 2016-му - реформа держзакупівель,
система ProZorro стала обов’язковою,
запрацював реєстр електронних декларацій, але
судова система залишалася нереформованою.
У 2017-му Україна вперше з 2010 року обійшла Росію,
НАБУ і САП розгорнули свою діяльність, але НАЗК
дискредитувало себе, а запуск Антикорупційного суду гальмувався.
Фактично з року в рік Україна набирала по 1-2 бали і
після Революції гідності загалом додала 6 балів.
За словами експертів, темпи дуже повільні.
Цього можна було досягти за рік, а не за п’ять.
Тобто темпи не відповідають обіцянкам політиків,
які зараз при владі, що боротьба з корупцією - їхній головний пріоритет.
Бракує політичної волі, політики хочуть не змінювати систему,
а прагнуть контролювати її. Українці ще не відчули,
що прямим наслідком корупції та хабарництва стане покарання.
Заява Олександра Вілкула про те, що
такої страшенної корупції, як зараз, в Україні
ще ніколи не було, не відповідає дійсності.
Насправді 2013-й рік, коли сам політик працював
віце-прем’єром, був найгіршим в Індексі сприйняття корупції за новою методологією.
Експерти пояснюють: враження, що корупції
в українському суспільстві нині побільшало,
зумовлено тим, що про корупційні порушення
оприлюднюється багато журналістських розслідувань,
випадки корупції дедалі важче приховати,
ніж раніше. Крім того, створено низку важливих
антикорупційних структур: НАБУ, САП та НАЗК,
до яких хоча все ще багато зауважень, але які
поступово починають діяти. Особливо великі
сподівання - на роботу Антикорупційного суду.